wer kennt es nicht man spielt
entspannten kartenspiel und muss viele
karten aus teilen der horror das dauert
dann nicht nur immer ewig wenn man mit
vielen leuten spielt man verzählt sich
auch noch ständig vor allem bei karten
spielen wo man teilweise über zehn
karten jeweils aus teilen muss aber das
schlimmste ist man hat derweil keine
kohle automatisch karten gang und genau
das problem werde ich mich jetzt kümmern
indem ich genau so eine coole
automatisch karten anbau die automatisch
karten aus teil für die entwicklung
werde ich natürlich auch einige karten
brauchen deswegen freue ich mich dass
dieses video von der pokémon company
unterstützt wird die mir ultra viele
booster packs der neuen pokémon
sammelkartenspiel erweiterungen schwert
und schild erst drei glanz zur verfügung
gestellt hat jetzt auch im handel
erhältlich sind aber wie soll das
kartenhaus zahl gerät überhaupt
funktionieren der youtuber mark webber
hat zum beispiel mal eine gerätschaft
gebaut die ununterbrochen alle geladenen
spielkarten mit maximaler
geschwindigkeit herausschießen wir
wollen ja aber eine genau einstellbare
anzahl an karten ausgeben und diese
geschwindigkeit würde bei einem normalen
spiel haben wahrscheinlich keine
probleme lösen sondern eher welche
machen für unseren apparat brauchen also
nicht nur einen motor der die ganze zeit
gas gibt wie ein verrückter solange man
den knopf drückt sondern auch einen
zweiten anderen motor einen sogenannten
schrittmotor der sich immer exakt so
weit dreht wie man es ihm sagt man soll
also an einem drehrad einsteigen können
wie viele karten mann aus teilen will
dann drückt man einen knopf am abzug uns
der präzise schrittmotor dreht sich
genauso oft jemand eingestellt hat und
schiebt über eine kleine vorrichtung pro
umdrehung jeweils genau eine karte nach
vorne wo sie dann vom schnellen gleich
motor sanft aber bestimmt
rausgeschleudert wird direkt auf dem
tisch vor den jeweiligen spieler dann
wird man von seinen freunden gefeiert
die menschenmengen erheben sich laut
google bricht aus
also zumindest hätte ich mir das so vor
um dahin zu kommen muss das
vollautomatische aus gerät aber erstmal
gebaut werden und davor erst mal die
sein werden weil wir uns gerade im umzug
von köln hin die münchner umgebung
befinden fange ich damit im zug anschlug
ich bin habe ich den schritt motor und
den gleichstrommotor einfach mitgenommen
um sie im zug aus zu messen und nach zu
modellieren damit ich das gehäuse meine
apparatur entsprechend anpassen kann da
ich dachte man könnte die genaue größe
von pokémon karten sicherlich einfach
googlen habe ich keinen rucksack
mitgenommen aber im internet finde ich
wirklich auf jeder seite eine komplett
unterschiedliche größenangabe deswegen
nicht dass später noch mal selbst genau
nachmessen muss nach und nach entsteht
also dass kartenfach inklusive
einlassungen für die beiden motoren
während die landschaft an mir vorbei
zischt
ich bin jetzt hier quasi neuen haus und
das was ich im zug nicht machen konnte
und zwar der pokémon kalt ausmessen das
mache ich jetzt dafür und generell für
dieses video aber die pokémon company
eine menge busse der erweiterung schwert
und schild erst ganz so gesendet die
mich jetzt auch machen werde
während einzelne strahlen denn geil
ich mag politik
[Musik]
geil ich habe einfach ein jesuit
produkte sowie pokémon die man aus
pokémon legende matthäus kennt gibt
übrigens zum ersten mal in der neuen
erweiterung jetzt hab ich auf jeden fall
mehr als genug hat nun herauszufinden
welche genauen abmaße die haben in der
dicke sind wir tatsächlich bei 0,3
millimeter laut einer quelle im internet
sind jetzt 88 9 millimeter lang sein
sind doch mehr aber genau 88 mm lang und
einstands 63,5 mm breit sind die
tatsächlich 63,2 mm breit und ja es ist
kein großer unterschied aber für mich
tatsächlich ein ziemlich wichtiger
unterschied deswegen muss ich noch mal
meine zeichnung jetzt anpassen
damit haben jetzt wie vorhin schon
eigentlich die ganze technik da oben
liegen die ganzen karten drin die stadt
will man einfach rein dann haben anhin
präzise ansteuerbaren motor bei denen
sie dann dieses bauteil dreht und genau
ein mal pro umdrehung eine karte hier so
ein stück weit nach rechts rüber schiebt
diese karte wird dann von hier einmal
nach rübergezogen kommen dann in den
motor der die komplette zeit auf vollgas
läuft und wir da heraus geschossen das
heißt der eine motor sorgt immer präzise
dafür dass immer genauso viel karten
weitergegeben werden wie ich will und
der andere motor sorgt für die richtige
power jetzt fehlt er aber auch eine
batterie die mag ich glaube ich in den
griff so die batterie schiebe ich jetzt
mal da hin wo ich mir den griff von dem
gerät schafft vorstellen konnte hierbei
fiel dann noch der microcontroller das
ist so was wie ein mini computer nur
komplett anders überlegen wie man sich
positionieren möchte klar dass ich meine
batterie so das gefällt mir ganz gut und
darum herum machen wir jetzt ein gehäuse
[Musik]
nun will ich das ganze in 3d drucker
ausdrucken doch ich muss feststellen
dass mein flüssig hearts 3d drucker
kaputt ist und mir deshalb erst mal
einen neuen bestellen also starte ich
zwei uhr nachts plan b und versuche den
alten filament 3d drucker zum laufen zu
bringen ich stecke jetzt gerade mal auf
der 3d druck über nacht gehabt hat und
es sich nicht super geil aus es hat
durchgezogen aber es freut mich
übertrieben hart weil ich erst einmal
drei stunden noch mal dran sagt und
inspirieren und irgendwie alle meine 34
3 d drucker über diese probleme haben
das sieht richtig gut aus das waren die
nächsten teile drauf dann können uns
auch schon die elektronik kümmern
[Musik]
so alles bis auf dem griff ist jetzt
fertig um den kümmert man später wenn
die ganze elektronik auch wirklich
funktioniert wer 3d druck hat echt viel
besser funktioniert als gedacht ich gebe
das jetzt mal zum veranschaulichen ganz
grob mit kreppband zusammen normal
gehört jetzt das teil ja noch dran das
mache ich aber weg der mittel besser
rein schauen können und da nehme ich mir
mal ein paar karten zum beispiel dieses
wunderschöne risiko läge ich mir mal
hier drauf und hier unten kann der
schrittmotor immer die unterste karte
hier nach rechts raus schieben mit hilfe
von dieser ausruf schnecke die
tatsächlich genau wie ihr habt ihr
richtig schön federt so weit kommen
jetzt wieder ab und dann kommen jetzt
alle erst mal da ein stück gummi drauf
dann wenn das ganze trip hat so der
hilfen okay war mal schauen ob das
klappt deren bisschen skeptisch
tatsächlich aber scheint gut zu
funktionieren
so und damit hat das jetzt auf einer
karte also richtig gut krippen immer die
unterste karte wird dann hier über
geschoben passt genau durch diesen
schlitz habe ich auch befürchtet dass es
deinen liebsten wieder passgenau dadurch
und auch nicht zwei karten passender ich
hab fast genau eine karte tue ich habe
genau die dicke abgemessen genau
deswegen er kommt sogar noch dieses rad
darauf dass dank weil sie mit vollgas
die karten pack und drüber schießt auch
hier braucht man natürlich noch kurz ein
gummiband drüber damit dass schon grip
hat so auf seine seite kommen kleber
drauf auf der anderen ein bisschen
aktivator damit der kleber direkt hält
sondern kommen auch mal über eine spur
kleber drauf
sagt iwata und dann kann es auch schon
einmal eine rolle
so genau dieses rad wird dann eben hier
aufgesteckt soll wenn sie das rad dreht
sieht das quasi hier die karte einfach
mit durch und schießt vorne ganz
entspannt out die anpassungen für die
motoren hier die passen wirklich einfach
komplett perfekt wie angegossen davis
überhaupt keine probleme geben und die
einlassung für die schrauben hier bin
ich dann quasi später diese beiden
hälften zusammenschrauben werde die
passen auch der nächste schritt wird
sein dass ich das hier alles miteinander
verkabelt und diesen mikro kontrolle im
programmieren
[Musik]
ungefähr 22 stunden später bin ich jetzt
endlich weiter sich ein kleines display
hat genauer gesagt einem 7 segment dicke
oder der mir genau die zahl an stellt
die ich rein programmierer oder auch mit
ungefähr zwei stunden später habe ich
jetzt hier so ein kleines rädchen das
kann ich drehen und damit diese zahl
erhöhen und durch zurückdrehen aber
wieder bringen und ihr seht schon worauf
ich hinaus will das ist genau dieser
region bei dem ich einstellen kann wi fi
karten meine karten maschine raus rufen
soll dafür muss jetzt lernen wie man
dieses display ansteuert und lernen wie
man diesen regler hier ansteuert da
diese sieben segment display allerdings
etwas limitiert ist habe ich durch ein
vielseitigeres lcd display ersetzt
vielleicht könnt ihr den text zu
erkennen und jetzt lerne ich wie man
diesen schritt motor ansteuert so der
schritt motor läuft dreht jetzt aber
ersten auf durchgehend für yb ich stelle
das dann später ein dass er sich genau
so auftritt wie man möchte davor
fürchten jetzt allerdings erstmal
verbauen so verpasst ihr wunderschön
rein und dann mit zwei schrauben
befestigen haben kommen dadurch werden
aber gut festgezogen buch und jetzt
natürlich der moment auf den wir alle
gewartet haben schiebt das ding wirklich
eine karte funktioniert das überhaupt
also jetzt mal ein stapel pokémon karten
rain oh ha oder wieder mal die erste
garde hierüber geschoben das ist einfach
geil man das schädlich hatte tatsächlich
weit genug dass sie auch wirklich in
diesem jahr in die laufbahn von den
anderen motoren reinkommen flutsch und
weg dann kommt die nächste sagt rutscht
weg und dann kommt die nächste und die
pflegt man kommt wieder die nächste und
die wird auch direkt weggezogen ist ja
geil das ist komplett geil der macht
spaß ist es wirklich sehr sehr gut jetzt
ist es noch ein bisschen langsam hab ja
darum ein spiel das ist wirklich krass
okay ich bin mittlerweile unsere weiters
ist auch super spät ich bin laden das
ganze jetzt mit einem wunderschönen tor
ran sagt legen gut drin so ich will
jetzt aussieht wie karten nicht raus
haben will ich nie macht genau eine
antwort nur dann gibt der motor gas
nicht den kopf und
ok ist verhungert schade durch den knopf
nochmal
ja ok aber das war schon schwach durch
den stoff noch mal
[Musik]
durch den kopf nochmal
okay das land bis hin zu machen wir
nochmal
dieses kreis wo soll ich denn jetzt
einfach mal 5 card nein ich rede den
regler mal hoch auf 5 ich drücke den
knopf und
die entdeckung
[Musik]
1234 er ist es komplett bild das ding es
ist komplett gras aktuell ist es noch
ein bisschen gefährlich das heißt ich
habe jetzt drei probleme die behoben
werden müssen erstens das ding muss
zuverlässiger werden aktuell dürfte
immer irgendwie ein zuviel oder zuwenig
aus zweitens die einzelnen karten kommen
zu langsam hintereinander und drittens
die einzelnen karten kommen viel zu
schnell aber das konzept funktioniert
und absolut w trotzdem brauchen wir
natürlich eine lösung dafür dass die
karte noch in einem zu großen zeitlichen
abstand ausgeworfen werden bessere
motoren die auch von der größe her in
frage kommen konnte ich auf die schnelle
leider nicht auftreiben weshalb ich
zusammen mit der zweiten hälfte der
karten pistole eine art getriebe designt
habe das große zahnrad am schrittmotor
hat 36 zähne und das kleine dass
letztendlich die karten anschiebt nur
zehn jedes mal wenn sich der
schrittmotor also einmal komplett dreht
dreht sich dadurch das kleine zahnrad
3,6 mal es können also in der selben
zeit 3,6 mal so viele karten ausgeworfen
werden einziger nachteil die kraft wird
dadurch um das 3,6 fache verringert die
sollte aber hoffentlich trotzdem noch
genug sein es sind nun alle teile
ausgedruckt und wir haben jetzt genügend
das alles mal zusammen zu bauen jetzt
gebe ich hoffentlich das problem dass
die einzelnen karten so langsam
nacheinander kommt dafür nehme ich mir
den schritt motor jetzt mal hier von dem
teil weg und packt den in den griff er
nicht aber auch diese autor schnecke und
ersetzt sie durch eine andere bzw direkt
durch ein komplett anderes zahnrad so
das kann man es hier ganz cool reinlegen
doch hier so passt perfekt das ist ja
das passt nicht perfekt das ist richtig
und edelstein aber was nicht passt wird
passend gemacht und zu einer dem
lötkolben ihr habt getrennt und soll
jetzt passt wie angegossen jawohl pas
perfekte rhein wieder super service
verein jetzt schrauben wir das mal fest
[Applaus]
einmal zweimal und dann ist das fest
verbaut so dass kabel lege ich mich
einmal unten durch damit dass später
genau da nach unten führt genau passt
perfekt rein jetzt steht es fest sehr
gut sieht super geil aus armut mehr
hochwertig jetzt kommt der zweite teil 1
und 2 diese neue ausweis schnecke mit
zahnrad und kugellager dran die clips
sie jetzt hier mal die andere hälfte
waren kann sie jetzt was wir drehen
jetzt wenn ich das hier so zusammenfügen
das theoretisch so sei nicht klar ob
genug power hat
mir tatsächlich schwierig ist auch das
teil hier drückt gerade nur ein bisschen
größer und währenddessen vergabe nicht
das komplette teil das heißt einmal alle
kabel von mir da reinpacken
[Musik]
stück für stück nötig alle schaltkreise
zusammen die ich vorher mehr oder
weniger sorgfältig geplant habe hier
verbaut gerade unter anderem einen an-
und ausschalter der den gleichstrom
motor dauerhaft aktiviert und einen
knopf der den schrittmotor auslöst er
die karten in der gewünschten anzahl zum
gleichstrommotor jeeps der diese dann
wiederum beschleunigt und raus jahr also
ich habe einfach mal den ganzen tag
damit verbracht die elektronik hier von
meinem alten prototypen hier zu
übertragen in das produkt eine sache die
auch immer noch nicht gemacht habe ist
die software dich geschrieben habe oder
den kot den ich geschrieben habe auf
diesen kleinen mikrokontroller zu
übertragen und das ist mir jetzt
gesuchten das jetzt nicht nur jetzt
klappt es noch nicht geklappt doch jetzt
hat es geklappt geil ist aus dem moment
da war ist jetzt gekommen ich baue das
ding jetzt zusammen es funktioniert
alles so weit von der elektronik herz
weil sie allerdings nicht ob diese
zahnrad auch so funktioniere ich es mir
vorstelle deswegen bin ich jetzt mal
alles in die positionen die es sein
sollte ich steck quasi die beiden akkus
an
macht den schalter mal auf aus er
schaltet man sich auch verbaut werden
jetzt gleich jetzt muss ich eigentlich
noch die hälfte auf die hälfte drauf
legen und so dass ich habe im gehäuse
drin bleiben so das wird jetzt echt eine
herausforderung dafür zu sorgen dass das
irgend alles reinpasst okay es geht zu
auf knopfdruck dreht sich jetzt einmal
das ding läuft jetzt ein bisschen um
grund will man sieht wenn ich ein
bisschen drauf drücken und das werde
jetzt ein bisschen beheben und zwar
indem ich einfach verbieten und zwar mit
jetzt relativ primitiv
jetzt deutlich runder neue versuche ich
werde es auch mal mit diesen winzigen
schrauben hier dieses ding rein
schreiben weil das ist ein bisschen ein
humba kiel aktuell so wie wir jetzt im
keller gegangen für dieses kabel habe
ich halt darauf vergessen stellt sich
jetzt auch mal hier rein so
jetzt noch mal der moment da war das ein
bisschen verstaubt das ist zu das ist
drauf ich mache
ich drück
okay jetzt geht's im weg ist marie kahle
rein
und let's go
okay noch nicht ganz so wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe
das ist so geil wenn ich ein bisschen
darauf zurückgeht es okay ich drücke
jetzt einmal
sagt hier nochmal
sagt effekt jetzt hat er immer einmal
gemacht aber was passiert wenn ich es
mal hoch stellen die auf
[Musik]
das erste
wiedersehen auf knopfdruck macht er halt
den hier der schiebt ihr danach ja ok
ja
oh ja das ist ein guter autor bisher
wenn du die karten dann auch sein wird
hält sie ein bisschen weil und
vielleicht geht das so besser
weiß
folge die reinste so richtig
[Musik]
aber sie funktioniert erzähler jetzt
spinnt aber in elektronik das ist ja
etwas kaputt ich muss noch mal reingehen
es funktioniert klappt aber dann nichts
es ist an trick einmal von kropff es
dreht sich nicht reden regler hoch es
dreht sich aber als nicht so oft wie ich
es eingestellt hat gerade ging das noch
keine ahnung ich habe schon alles
mögliche probiert neue blüten hat auch
gut funktioniert jetzt irgendwie wieder
nicht vielleicht ist das bauteil defekt
ich ersetze wärme macht
[Musik]
oh mein gott es geht wieder hui das war
gott war ich da jetzt lange dran der sc
ist die zahlen bewegen sich wieder
stehen wieder hoch drehen ein
entsprechend bewegt sich wahrscheinlich
ja motor wieder länger geil ok perfekt
wir sind wieder im rennen auf der suche
nach der fehlerquelle habe ich leider
auch diesen alten drehregler gegen einen
einsatz teil ausgetauscht nur um dann
festzustellen dass er überhaupt nicht
die ursache für das problem war da ich
am alten drehregler aber schon diese
pins hier aufwendig modifiziert habe
damit sie ins gehäuse passen blöd ich
jetzt doch wieder hin philipp in den
neuen regler ab und den alten wieder
dran ok ich glaube es ist fertig als ich
habe erst mal so einen ordentlichen
stapel von dem pokémon karten genommen
legt die man hier ein bisschen kleiner
versorgt dass die karten auch für
vorbereitet beschwert werden wenn wir
die schönen durchrutschen ich mache das
gerät an und abfahrt
ja es funktioniert einfach schön ich
werde jetzt mal auf vier karten 1 1
234 einfach vier karten ausgeteilt und
dass man selbst etwas machen musste ist
komplett deswegen kommen zurück was für
ein krankes ding was möchte ich auch
machen keine all zu schießen und das ist
schon wirklich sehr cool
das projekt hat richtig spaß gemacht ich
habe ultra viel dazu gelernt das ist der
automatische der vollautomatische
kartenhaus teil extrem geiles teil die
neue pokémon sammelkartenspiel
erweiterung schwert und schild als drei
clowns ist jetzt überall im handel
erhältlich mit vielen neuen extrem
seltene pokémon karten wie zum beispiel
der brandort von schienen pokemon
strahlende pokémon mit schillernden
demonstrationen von denen nur eines in
einen sack mit aufgenommen werden kann
diese karten haben extrem mächtige
angriffe und fähigkeiten um die
begrenzte anzahl im deck auszugleichen
alle infos findet ihr jetzt über den
link in der beschreibung vielen dank an
die pokémon company für die
unterstützung bei diesem absoluten
projekt ich könnte mir als absolute fan
wohl wirklich keinen besseren sport
können video vorstellen und damit sage
ich schaue abonniert gerne kanal macht's
gut